I stand up nights thinking, and wake up every
mornings checking my phone, measuring my life
and self worth in quantifiable numbers, thinking
about all things I want to do, that I must
do, always thinking about my next step
wake up
work more,
you are not good enough
sleep less, work faster
work, go to sleep, wake up, do it all over
again
one weeks passes, more coffee more cigarettes
more distractions from my thoughts from my
emotions
there is always something that has to be done
before I can offer myself the time to feel,
the time to accept myself
I need to do more, sleep more , eat healthier,
exercise, be more social, work more, be better
in every aspect of life, it s not enough,
will never be enough, don t stop, can t stop
now, tomorrow will be better,
I need more and more of everything and only
afterwards I will feel safe and accepted
because how was I supposed to fill up the
emptiness inside of me, if not with achievements
or with material objects
just one single problem, there was never enough,
I was never satisfied
I was aching, terror was filling my heart,
waking up stressed every morning
a constant pressure everyday on being perfect,
I couldn t allow myself to be, I couldn t
accept myself
I have created for myself the perfect trap
of feeding my vicious beliefs
A voice behind my back always whispering you
are not good enough, and you will never be
never good enough to offer myself appreciation,
or compassion
no empathy or understanding for my own being
a submining behaviour in which I keep raising
the bar higher for myself, so I keep wanting
more
a clear path to destruction, and I was aware
of it
a continuous roaming of the mind in its own
endless maze until it meets total collapse
My own bubble of comfort whose walls used
to offer me safety, now were starting to constrain
themself onto me,
slowly cutting my breath, making me feel insignificant,
more and more day by day
Today It feels like the only safe space I
have is my own room, but actually it s my
most dangerous trap created by comfort, and
which will lead to my own destruction
so I am escaping,
escaping the city I live in, escaping the
pattern which was spiraling me down into a
deeper emotional numbing and less self awareness
of how I am neglecting myself and the people
around me
until one day, I won t be able to wake up
anymore, and I will be completely alone
Chapter One Awareness
this is a story of anxiety and how workaholism
is destroying my life,
a story of addiction many of us are living
in one form or another, and how I started
to escape workaholism
In this short movie I want to open up a little,
to explore and present my addiction, which
is workaholism, while showcasing some shots
from my trip to bucharest using the Sony Film
Simulation Picture Profiles
If you are not familiar with sony film simulations,
They are in camera picture profiles meant
to give you great color Straight out of camera
for both video and photo modes and I have
a full playlist on this subject, so you can
go check it out on my channel
I just purchased the sigma 24 f2 contemporary
which is an absolute beauty and wanted to
test it in a more lively context compared
to my hometown, which is a very quiet place.
So I decided I needed something new, a new
environment to push me out of my comfort zone,
out of my room out of my apartment, to see
everything with a new perspective
something to fix me in the moment
and what better place than a capital city?
So I planned my trip to bucharest
Woke up after sleeping 12 hours in the chair.
Got off the train half asleep everything seemed
like moving slowly & fast, in the same time.
Sun was rising rapidly without patience and
people were hurrying up to find their place,
so I anxiously followed the flow and started
searching for the first moment to capture.
I had multiple film simulation that I wanted
to showcase in this video, like the kodachrome
ektar100, and cinestill50D, senova light,
kodak gold and cinechrome, but after trying
out the new cinechrome film simulation I just
fell in love with with it and I sticked with
it most of the time
I ll put the name of the film simulations
used under each shot so you can decide for
yourself which one is your favorite
The footage was all graded using my film power
grades which you can find on my website, but
the photos are straight out of camera to showcase
the colors and image you can get without editing
just by using these sony film simulations.
Chapter 2 Angst
I had all these film simulations and I didn
t know which one to start with, I felt overwhelmed
trying to decide which should best fit the
situation? Or atleast mirror my own mood?
But what was my mood? What was I feeling,
I actually didn t know because everything
was masked by a feeling of overwhelmedness
it s morning people are in action, the sun
is low creating interesting shapes to work
with, and as I was walking I took a couple
shots in my frenetic desperation to capture
something, but it all felt off,
but couldn t focus and i ve lost so many moments,
So I panicked
I felt like between two walls which seemed
to get closer to each other in an alarming
state.
I was supposed to come together with 2 friends,
but they canceled, so I ended up alone, which
made me even more anxious, paralyzed, I couldn
t gather the courage to go out alone.
I was in a ruth, doing the same things everyday,
unconsciously engaging in the same unhealthy
behaviors, ignoring the signs my body or my
mind were giving me
I was living just like a mindless robot,
even tho I am still young, i ve Never felt
as old and helpless as I did in this moment
I couldn t control my life, I had no energy
to take the responsibility for my own decisions,
so I was piloting this body on auto mode,
I was living inside an illusion, hoping things
will get better without me trying
it is so stupidly simple
something I used to do which such ease in
the past, now seems like a huge wall which
is impossible to be climbed
I am not even capable of leaving my home to
exercise in the park or to take a walk, what
about leaving home to visit another city all
by myself?
This was a bad idea
Why am I feeling like this? It shouldn t be
such a big deal, i ve done this so many times
in the past, why is it so hard right now?
I feel lethargic and I feel shame, I feel
like a failure, like I will end up being nobody,
because I keep feeling more and more anxious,
more overwhelmed of life and all the changes
going on these days.
I do not feel safe in my own home, I cannot
feel safe around my closest friends, I can
barely feel safe with myself alone, and that
for how long?
How long till I won t be able to handle myself
either?
Well, you know what, I am done feeling bad,
i m reframing my life to a new direction
I am stil scared as hell, but I choose to
go, I choose to jump into the endless pit
of anxiety
Chapter 3 Letting go
As the rush hour was on a decline, there were
less and less people on the streets,and the
sun was rising menacingly
It already seems pretty bad, I just got there
but already felt like I am behind schedule.
there was not much to do, it felt like a bad
start of a day, but I didn t want to quit.
Suddenly a voice in my head stopped me and
reminded me why I was there.
I came to relax, I came to experiment, there
is no final destination to reach, there are
no goals to achieve. There is only me and
time. Time to explore.
So I dialed in the settings for Cinechrome
which was never tested before on the field
and I just started to give myself a moment
I
slowly calmed down and started to feel the
city
Everything started to slowly fall into place
slowly everybody refuged in their own affairs
most of them working, some starting to find
shelter from the burning sun which was looking
more and more menacing as it was rising up
over the endless concrete jungle..
So I was wondering where can I find people
and stories at this late hour?
I just walked around, taking shots of buildings,
waiting for something unique to happen, something
out of the ordinary.
People say bucharest is a concrete jungle,
and it s true, but I was amazed to see how
many parks and green spots they had.
Every street was filled with trees, and every
zone had atleast 1 huge park.
I started losing track of my map, I just swirled
around being attentive to everything happening
around me,
and suddenly it came to me
it just clicked, my anxiety melted and I was
in touch with my surroundings,
I just realized one of my most valuable lessons
for street photography up to this moment,which
is in street photography, just like life in
general, is not about always moving around,
hunting frenetically for the next moment,
the next hype.
sometimes is a calling for meditation, for
being still, in the moment, in the same spot,
and without realizing, the beauty of life
unwraps before you.
Chapter 4
Take a Moment
There is a certain charm to this city, to
the streets, the people. Everybody is open
and so friendly.
Coming from a small town, where people look
oddly uncertain at you if you have a camera
around your neck, bucharest was a lovely invitation
to playfulness.
How the lights fall onto the street, the architecture,
the shops the smile of the people when they
realize you took their shot. There is a certain
magic to this city, and They all seemed so
be enjoying being part of the process. As
much as I did
it s my second time visiting bucharest, and
I absolutely love it
Unfortunately I won t use too many pictures
with recognizable people because I don t want
anyone to be offended. I tried to ask most
people if they mind if I took their picture,
but I never asked them if they d like to appear
in my video, so to respect their identity
I will post only pictures of unrecognizable
people
Shortly I realized I was enjoying myself and
started shooting absolute random nothingness.
After walking around in circles for a couple
hours, I came to the conclusion that it s
time to move to another zone
Chapter 5 Stillness
the sun is high and strong so I shelter in
one of my favorite parks
everything starts to move slowly and gentle,
time feels like taking a break as well in
this sunny day and everything starts to feel
a little bit more colorful in my eyes
I just walked around, observing
birds chirping, people were relaxing in the
shade, some were sunbathing and kids were
playing
it was a very calm place to be
I really love these shots, seeing these kids
playing reminded me very much of my childhood
and how I used to play in the summer time
with sticks or pretty much anything I could
find
everything felt different in those times,no
worries on my mind, everything seemed to move
slow and my heart was filled with curiosity
to explore, nowadays it s hard to reconnect
or feel the same
but
even tho I am different, maybe it s time to
reconnect
after a quiet and relaxing stroll through
the park I decide it s time to explore new
areas
There is something about public transportation
that really makes me feel excited, especially
the subway
Maybe it s the lights, the changing levels
of underground, maybe how the wind is blowing
like the storm is coming, the smell of basement,
and the stories, I just love it all
probably no place holds as many stories as
the subway,
they ve seen it all
when you were rushing late in the morning,
when you were having a good laugh being drunk
with your friends, when you smirked because
you received a text from somebody special,
And also when you were alone, and you held
inside the tears because there was nobody
to hold you
it s all in the subway
I love observing and taking part of stories,
it s where most inspirations takes form
A place where you can start to feel and understand,
that we are all people, fragile and vulnerable
human beings.
and sometimes that s all we need, someone
to listen and to understand us
but instead we are taught how to be strong
individuals, how to be heartless, how to ignore
our emotions & leave our human traits behind,
because it only shows weakness
We need to be helped, not pushed down
CHAPTER 6 Connection
at this point I was shooting mindlessly, it
was such an easy pleasure, walking around
everything seemed of interest to me, not regretting
at all knowing that I was going to spend hours
deleting the useless shots i've taken
I felt so free with all my worries melted,
everything seemed so real and in place, just
like it s supposed to be
I was seeing something unique on every street,
and it was the first time I felt so inspired
in so long
I wasn't just a ball of anxiety anymore, my
mind wasn't overreacting and overthinking
everything
it was stillness
and finally I felt connected to my inner self
coming here alone was not a mistake, and it
was not by chance
it was all part of my journey of reconnecting
it was my liberation.
Chapter 7 Uncertainty
as the sun goes down, the ambiance of the
city changes as well,
People starting to be less friendly, and more
skeptical of any interactions, especially
in the areas that I wanted to explore, which
were pretty dangerous night time
I myself, became more aware of what is going
on around me, since the ambiance changes from
block to block, and suddenly sketchy folks
started to appear on the streets.
one street can be peaceful with pretty houses,
while the next one full shady people roaming
around.
overall I it felt great revisiting bucharest
and this trip was exactly what I needed, but
with empty streets and nothing going on, it
s slowly getting boring, and it felt like
it s time to go home
But one funny thing is, I wanted this trip
to be as spontaneous as possible, so I decided
last minute to leave, and didn't check what
time is the train returning hometown
usually there are trains every couple hours,
so didn't take into consideration my next
train will leave only the following day at
6 am
it was around 11:30 pm and overall i've been
walking 18 hours straight
I was really tired, my body was aching for
sleep and I still had more than 6 hours to
wait till I could leave bucharest
there were no rides or other transportation
i could take to my hometown at that late hour.
So to speed up the remaining time I went back
on the streets,
but out of the sudden, everything changed
completely and got really creepy,
couple hour passes by shooting mindlessly,
listening to the streets, being aware of every
sound happening around me,
But with streets being completely desolated
and at times weird people appearing from nowhere,
I didn't feel that comfortable anymore walking
all by myself
the subway was also closing so I had to take
my final ride for the night
I wasn't aware of this aspect either, I thought
I will be able to travel with the subway all
night
Unfortunately the last stop was not exactly
at the train station,
I was in a rather dangerous part of the city
at around 1-2am, and I had to go by foot all
the way back to the train station
Chapter 8 Reflection
coming out of the subway, I notice people
whispering in distance and groups of people
rapidly disappearing behind corners. It was
all pretty sketchy
Suddenly 2 guys appeared, riding their bikes
strangely close to me,
everything seemed rather uneasy and I was
very cautious of my surroundings
it was all so silent
there was nobody on the street, only some
cars passing by
there was no restaurant or fast food open,
no place to waste my time in safety until
the morning comes.I eventually decided it
would be safest to go back at the train station
and wait for the morning to come
So walked back to the station and waited there,
together with a couple people who were also
commuting to Bucharest from smaller cities,
they were also waiting for the the night to
end
I spoke to one guy, he was such a kind soul
but very unfortunate
for the last 3 years he has been working without
any contract in Bucharest, as a daily worker
business owners come pick him up together
with other job seekers and they promise them
work for a day, sometimes 1 week or if you
re lucky 1 month,
But many times he finds no work for weeks,
so he stays in the strain station, homeless,
because he has nothing better to do in his
small town
he believes he has no other way of earning
money, and he will never find a good job because
people won t hire him.
He wasn't sure if he should stay one more
day or not, he had 5 bucks left, that was
all his money, which was his train ticket
money.
He didn't beg for money, he wasn't trying
to use his story for me to pity him
I could see the sorrow, the honesty and the
true soul of this man
I approached him and he just opened up to
me, which I appreciated
he deserved more, but he couldn't see the
opportunities he could have
his story really touched me, so after I gave
him some food money and my goodbyes, I started
reflecting on how much do we need to loose
in this life to realize of what we had in
front of us?
His story made me realize how ungrateful I
can be at times, and how much luck I had in
comparison to others to have the life of mine,
or at least for the chance to be aware, to
be able to choose new perspectives. Just because
I knew I had a choice and a chance for a better
life, the luck of having hope to change things,
hope which this man had no more.
it s not much, but even this little awareness
is a such a privilege.
it s never our job to judge and bring people
down, but try to help them be their best,
little by little.
Because that s why we become addicted,
and ill minded,
and angry,
and mad,
because we cannot relate to one another.
Because we feel so misunderstood
because we feel like we don t belong
because we cannot stand each other.
But what if we just stopped for a second and
listened to the ones close to us
realize we are all humans, we are not perfect,
we ll make so many mistakes
And that is part of the process, so instead
of separation and hate, let s try to understand
each other
because that is all we seek as humans, we
seek appreciation through various forms,
isn't compassion our most powerful tool in
resolving problems and overcoming our own
ego?
Compassion towards our self
towards the ones around us
understanding which fulfills the emptiness
our trauma left behind,
more than achievements, more than cars, and
rings, clothes and material objects.
only if we allow our self to be vulnerable
and a new perspective arises
a new world is built right in front of us
a world of humanity and connection
a world where we make mistakes, but a world
where we also fix what we've broken
and a place to exist with all our differences
for everybody to be together, in community
hopefully this video helped you see a new
perspective
And Thank you for watching!